hi
my name is ryan and i'd like to tell you
about different ways you can run code on
google cloud
in the next few minutes we'll talk about
how you can use virtual machines
serverless computing containers and more
to run code in the cloud
ready let's get started
as we mentioned in the first video of
google cloud essentials cloud computing
is all about getting things done using
someone else's computers
with google cloud you're getting things
done using google's computers
there are several different compute
products you can use to run code on
google cloud
these options range from highly managed
to highly customizable
on the highly managed side google
abstracts more of the backend server and
infrastructure logic so you can get up
and running quickly
on the highly customizable side you as a
developer are in charge of more of the
backend server and infrastructure logic
but this gives you more flexibility to
customize these options for your use
case let's take a closer look at some of
these compute products and when you may
want to use them
on the highly managed side we have
firebase are you building a mobile app
that requires little back-end code
if so firebase might make sense for you
firebase is google's app development
platform that includes key features like
a database storage functions
authentication notifications and more
this makes it great for use cases where
most of the processing is done on the
client side rather than the server side
perhaps you're building a quiz game for
ios and android
with firebase you can store quiz
questions in the cloud firestore
database help users log in with firebase
authentication and store profile photos
in firebase storage
but what if your application does need
some back-end code but you still want a
highly managed solution if so you might
want to check out cloud functions cloud
functions is designed for event driven
applications
for example maybe you own an e-commerce
business and want to automatically send
a welcome email whenever a new user
creates an account
with cloud functions you can write code
that runs in response to such events and
you can do this without having to manage
servers containers or infrastructure
using cloud functions is simple
all you do is write a function and
deploy it to the cloud
you can do so with programming languages
like python ruby php nodejs java go and
net
functions can be triggered by http
events like a user visiting a url
they can also be triggered when
something happens in another google
cloud product like when a database like
cloud firestore is updated
cloud functions scale automatically so
you only pay when your function is
executed
they also support long processing times
concurrency and 90 plus native
integrations
several common use cases for cloud
functions include serverless mobile
backends iot back-ends real-time file
processing and virtual assistants
however it may not always be the case
that your code can be separated into
different independent functions if you
need a compute product to help you
manage an entire application but still
want a relatively managed solution check
out app engine app engine is great for
deploying web apps and other backend
applications to the cloud
as a fully managed application platform
app engine lets you focus on your code
rather than everything that google cloud
does behind the scenes to run your app
on google's computing infrastructure
in particular app engine's auto scaling
makes it easy to scale up and down to
meet the demands of your users
let's say you have an online retail
business for children's toys
when your website receives spikes of
traffic during the holiday season app
engine will automatically scale your
application up and when traffic returns
to normal afterwards app engine will
scale back down so that you only pay for
the computing resources you actually
need
additionally app engine handles other
things for you like load balancing
traffic splitting error reporting and
more
instead of worrying about the backend
infrastructure you can focus on your
core
features if you want to take advantage
of running your app in containers check
out cloud run and kubernetes engine
first on the highly managed side we have
cloud run
cloud run lets you develop and deploy
highly scalable containerized
applications in the programming language
of your choice on a fully managed
serverless platform
you can use cloudron to deploy any
stateless http container it is useful
for synchronous event driven
applications and microservices
this allows you to benefit from the
scalability and abstraction of
serverless computing while benefiting
from the additional flexibility
containers give you in terms of
programming languages runtimes and
libraries
with cloudron you can let it handle
tasks like monitoring application health
and troubleshooting
in similar to app engine cloud run
automatically and quickly scales up or
down based on your incoming traffic and
even scales down to zero
you only pay for the resources that your
app uses build down to the nearest 100th
millisecond
cloudron is a great place to start for a
container-based workload however if you
want to have more operational control
over the infrastructure running these
containers you can check out google
kubernetes engine google kubernetes
engine or gke runs kubernetes the open
source container orchestration platform
on a managed cluster of virtual machines
kubernetes provides a set of apis that
allow you to more granularly control the
lifecycle of your containers including
how you expose them to clients how you
auto scale them what machines they run
on and how you monitor them
gke provides additional management
layers for kubernetes some expose to you
to perform tasks like making managing
cluster upgrades easier and some
completely taken care of by google like
making sure the most critical kubernetes
components are fully managed
one key difference between cloud run and
kubernetes engine is the pricing model
while cloud run pricing is based on
usage the standard mode for kubernetes
engine pricing is based on the virtual
machines that are used with one
exception
for those who are already familiar with
the kubernetes api but want usage based
pricing and a more fully managed mode of
a gke cluster they can turn to gke's
autopilot mode
on the highly customizable side we have
compute engine compute engine gives you
virtual machines for you to run your
code on
basically anything that you can run on a
computer you can run on a compute engine
virtual machine
while the previous compute options
abstract away much of the server and
infrastructure management compute engine
gives you more responsibility to manage
the server and infrastructure tasks
yourself
while this can add additional
responsibility to your development and
operations teams it also gives you more
flexibility to customize your computing
resources the way you want even with a
custom os image
this means that you can easily run your
existing applications on compute engine
without having to make many changes to
your software
so there you have it an overview of
several different ways you can run code
on google cloud ranging from highly
managed to highly customizable
although these compute products serve
different use cases many developers use
several of them together to support an
overall application architecture
for example a game developer may host a
database on firebase a game server on
kubernetes engine and an email
integration on cloud functions
make sure to check out other episodes of
google cloud essentials where we cover
topics like storing data on google cloud
the google cloud console the google
class ck key use cases and more i can't
wait to see what you build with google
cloud
[Music]
you